today's topic it seems like Matt re is
always in the news Matt R is beefing
with a six-year-old that's the question
I was asking myself this morning when I
I came back from my my 2 days away from
the internet and that for some reason
was the first headline I saw and I was
just like why how like did Matt lose a
spelling be but as it turns out you know
he had the previous controversy you know
he made a domestic violence joke in his
Netflix special a lot of the women who
watched him not liking that and his
response to the backlash was if I
offended you I think it was a lot of
woman not watching him
not likeing or not liking that it's a
lot of non fans want be it's a lot of
girls that was not watching him that did
not like that then this part ended up
being connected to influencer bunny
hidea because she let her six-year-old
son respond to one of R's jokes where he
mocked girls who were into astrology
nothing to do with the Stars man just
because Jupiter has a ring and you don't
doesn't mean it's Saturn that has to
rings and it has more also and you're
mean to girls with bunny than saying
even though she doesn't post a lot about
her son her followers know that he loves
space and a lot of people Tagg her in
the Matt R clip so that then bunny
posted a new Tik Tok over the weekend
well she said she thought the original
video was kind of this light-hearted
little whatever it's my kid being quippy
saying Matt R wasn't even tagged it was
stitched to Netflix and apparently Matt
R did not like this video when he saying
that R commented and posting a
screenshot of the alleged comment
reading Jupiter also has a ring oh and
Santa Claus isn't real your mom buys you
presents with a money she makes on only
fans good luck with that comment is
not
I like
that yeah I like that all right I
approve Matt Matt's wi me over the
triple down brother keep it going so the
first thing she calls out is his claim
that she makes money on only fans I
don't even show my body it doesn't
matter doesn't matter it doesn't matter
the joke was accurate you're on only fan
you're making money on only fan so it
could be a joke about you showing your
pom poom but he didn't even mention that
no he just said you made money on only
fans for you to assume that every single
woman online makes money by showing
their bodies which like if that's what
you do girl do you like love it I have
never made a single dollar from a man
audience is female female female female
and a little bit of the Gaz and N you
can't
accept do you know the sexual
orientation of every single one of your
subscribers I'm a call cap on that but
anyways no it's not that is that you
know the way she said oh yeah I don't
make money you didn't say nothing about
the body and everything stuff uh I don't
make many of a man not a single man just
it's a bunch of girls and gays they're
not men that's the reason why they gay
it's cuz they man bro she she she has to
sell the whole misogynous angle so she
inserted stuff into his comment that
wasn't there yeah okay you just want to
assume that I no no I said you make
money on you want to assume that my
[__] no but I just said you you make
money on only fans yeah I make money on
only fans but now by selling my body
like your mogist okay no you don't make
I don't even make money on rolling fans
I said Santa Claus is not real your mom
been paying that [__] with the money she
makes on only fans do you make money on
only fans if I'm that right do you make
money on only fans that's the fact that
people may like women for their
personalities no you we know you don't
have one and in response you have people
criticizing right saying things like he
just digs himself deeper what kind of
man beefs with a literal child as well
as Matt R is behaving more like a
6-year-old than an actual 6-year-old
also with this you had bring up that
this is not the first time he's ever
gone after a child there people pointing
back to a joke that he made about a
birth mark Mason Ramsay had or the viral
yodeling
kid y
really that was a viral you could get it
Hey listen jokes jokes about public kids
are fine yo you know how many jokes
people used to do about moli culen
growing up that was like one of the
greatest things you could do M Michael
Jackson and moli moli and mcau just
mallan whatever okay these people are
knock knock who's there maau cin that
was a joke these are public figures okay
not that not some people defending Matt
R like if you go to his Instagram people
get mad at him talk about oh how could
you say that to a kid why is this
[__] six-year-old on Instagram why is
this mom using him to clap back at other
creators it's like you guys want to
throw these people right into the line
of fire surprised when they catch a
stray as a parent I'm going to be honest
you're the one who needs to hold the L
you don't like the fact that people are
commenting stuff on what your kid has to
say then maybe you shouldn't have your
kid up here arguing with grown people on
Instagram that you edit and put together
for your own brand benefit there's
certain things like that I don't like
from parents and then they want to oh
how could you my child yeah you gave
your child a sword and Let It Go
swinging everywhere surprised when
somebody kicked the sword out of his
hand and hurt them the thing that we
face on The
Daily the comments that we face on The
Daily you [__] are ruthless you
don't give a [__] because you're not fa
to face with a person you're talking to
now I want to subject I wouldn't subject
a six-year-old to that
I want to subject I chose
this I chose to do this the people
around me have it you understand what
I'm saying so putting your six-year-old
I find cringe when you put all them sixy
olds and all them kids out there on your
social media whether you make money of
it or where you don't make money of it
when you don't make money of it I feel
it's even more pathetic CU it's really
just for attention you know what I mean
at least you could buy groceries with
the money but I digress yeah the minute
you put your people
on social media you put your people in
the public they are subjected to catch
anything absolutely you put you put them
you put them in arms way you you did
that so knowing what people do what
people my R just did a joke it's a joke
oh he's going to do a little joke I'm
going to do a little joke haha that's it
it went a little too far for you cuz you
assume stuff about the only fans and the
fact that you sell your booty you sell
your beauty and it's fine and it's okay
but you still don't only F didn't
mention none of that yo listen there's a
lot of assumption there but it's fine
it's fine and whether you shouldn't talk
about people's families when it comes to
like content creation if someone's a
content creator and you going back and
forth with them you don't talk about
their families now if your wife want to
get up on this platform and also talk
she know she she's now a Crea herself
she can get it that's it that's it you
don't get veil of add oh this my why is
your family getting involved and also
why is this kid saying stuff like Matt R
you're not nice to girls who taught him
that I know this [__] he's six
he shouldn't be watching anything for
Matt r no so who taught him that who
coached him to make this video My Girl
your [__] start not to add up your [__]
start not to add up cuz I hope the I
hope the [__] he was not watching that
special and if he wasn't he's not even
supposed to know who Matt re is Boo
you used your child for clout yo and
guess what you can get it he got the
clout you y he got it from Matt R and it
could be it could be it could be good
clout or bad clout is just something
that happen yep right it could could be
it could be good it could be really bad
when it's good it's good absolutely but
when it's bad you just you just be lucky
that that was just the bad that he got
man there's a lot of content I can make
with family memb significant others and
make lots of money off there's a reason
why I don't do it mhm uh 100% now if you
want to pretend like you don't know why
it's fine but don't act like a victim
afterwards you know what I mean if you
want to yo [__] you and F [__]
everything about you too if you want to
go do that with your family don't don't
don't cry afterwards that's it the
minute you step the minute you step in
the public eye you could get these jokes
I don't care how old you are absolutely
the minute you step up but I'm disabled
you can get it that's right you step in
the public eye you can 100% get it yo
listen you want to use your kid to make
money cool you got to pay taxes
but it's my you got to pay taxes it's
just because he's a six-year-old making
all this tread don't mean he don't pay
taxes and now you you paying the joke
tax so good for you it is what it is all
right I think this is going to be good
for Matt and Matt's brand I think he's
going to have more that I don't give a
[__] in a lot of people going respect it
and love it and I think he's going to
gain fans from this and the fans he's
going to lose were probably fans he
never wanted to because now he gets to
express himself more freely so at the
end of the day big dub for mat and as
far as this lady goes any weirdo who
want to use their kids online I I don't
really I don't really jive with that I
think it's weird when people do family
and putting their kids on Front Street
especially to argue with other grown-ups
with the adults that's weird to me
that's super weird that's my thoughts on
that anything else you want to say no
[__] the kids [__] them
kids you [__] them kids bro [__] them
hold on hold on hold on [__] them public
ass kids yeah s Claus this isn't real
huh huh and if your mom got a only
fans
she's selling her pom poom there's
pictures I don't believe in PG-13 only
fans I don't believe in that oh it is I
don't believe in none of [__] I don't
believe it fake news fake news we know
why you on only fans we know why you're
not on patreon okay it's because your
booty hole out there in the streets well
I mean only find is a better
platform it is look who's about to start
one too hello who want to see priest get
boo boo naked how Bo boom boom boom boom
boom boom naked boom boom naked yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you don't know what
boom boom naked is the [__] out of you
know what boom boom naked is get the
[__] out of here when you blow up that
[__] when you blow up that [__] boom
boom
naked y you never heard of this NOP it's
okay you need to get online you outside
too much yeah I'm outside all right let
us know what you guys think in the
comments